just to stick on alien life for just a
brief
moment more is there is some signs of
signs of life on venus in gaseous form
there's uh hope for life
on mars probably extinct we're not
talking about intelligent life
although that has been in the news
recently we're talking about basic like
you know uh bacteria bacteria yeah
and then also i guess uh there's a
couple moons
yeah your europa which is jupiter's moon
i think there's another one are you um
is that exciting or is it terrifying to
you that we might find life
do you hope we find life i certainly do
hope that we find life
um i mean it was very exciting to
to hear about uh you know uh this
uh news about the the possible life
on the venus it'd be nice to have hard
evidence
of something with uh which is what the
hope is for
for mars and and europa but do you think
those organisms will be similar
biologically or would they even be sort
of carbon based
if we do find them i would say they
they would be carbon based how similar
it's a big question right so it's it's
know the moment we discover things
outside earth right even if it's a tiny
little
single cell i mean there's
so much just imagine that that would be
so
i think that that would be another
turning point for for the science you
know
and if especially if it's different in
some very new way
that's exciting because that says that's
a definitive state not a definitive but
a pretty strong statement that life is
everywhere in the in the
in the universe to me at least that's
that's really exciting
you